[Música]
hola soy mago tu asistente virtual tengo
algo que preguntarte estamos totalmente
a oscuras lo que significa que nadie te
está mirando y nadie te va a juzgar
quiero que respondas con total
sinceridad
qué es lo último que hiciste ayer antes
de irte a dormir y qué es lo primero que
has hecho al despertar esta mañana por
favor levanta la mano si la respuesta a
las dos preguntas anteriores es mirar el
móvil
adelante
perfecto gracias ya puedes bajar la mano
hola acabáis de conocer a la maga
virtual yo soy la más real
desde hace 5 años más o menos me dedico
profesionalmente al social media
marketing o marketing en redes sociales
y por mi trabajo pasó entre 6 y 8 horas
al día más o menos conectada
al principio de verano decidí
desconectarme durante varias semanas de
las redes sociales y ahora os quiero
contar el porqué
os decía hace un momento que paso entre
seis y ocho horas al día conectada y a
lo mejor pensáis que es normal porque me
dedico a esto pero que el resto de la
gente seguramente no pase tantas horas
conectada verdad bueno pues los datos
dicen otra cosa sabéis cuánto tiempo
pasamos los españoles de media
conectados al día
5 horas y 18 minutos
y también está demostrado que miramos el
móvil más de 100 veces al día esto
significa que cada diez minutos dejamos
de hacer lo que estemos haciendo para
mirar si tenemos algo nuevo en el móvil
interrumpimos lo que estemos haciendo
aunque estemos hablando con alguien
haciendo cualquier tarea o incluso lo
que es peor aunque vayamos conduciendo
os imaginais tener un bote con 100
caramelos y cada diez minutos sentir la
necesidad de uno de estos
caramelos y comerlo
os imaginais además que cada diez
minutos
os imagináis que si os separéis tres o
cuatro metros de ese bote de caramelos
empezáis a sentir síntomas de ansiedad
porque esto es lo que está pasando
actualmente con la tecnología digital y
con nosotros y si esta tendencia
continúa al llegar al final de nuestra
vida
habremos pasado más tiempo mirando una
pantalla que cualquier otra cosa
os voy a contar algo hace tres meses iba
conduciendo en mi coche y sonó una
notificación en el móvil no pude
aguantar las ganas de mirar que era y lo
hice lo miré era un comentario sin
importancia que me habían dejado
en una foto de instagram en menos de una
milésima de segundo perdí el control de
mi coche y me estrellé
afortunadamente desperté en mi cama
porque había sido un sueño una pesadilla
más bien porque fue tan real tan real
que no me pude volver a dormir tenía la
necesidad de seguir tirando de ese hilo
de seguir investigando y sabéis lo que
descubrí que la principal causa de
atropellos en españa' es precisamente
que no tenemos capacidad de reacción
suficiente por ir mirando el móvil por
la vía
también me enteré que de cada tres
accidentes graves de tráfico en uno de
ellos el conductor iba mirando el móvil
descubrí muchas cosas más pero creo que
ya veis por dónde vale al final me fui a
dormir y cuando desperté al día
siguiente tomé la decisión iba a pasar
varias semanas de rehabilitación digital
no solamente por lo que se contaba hasta
ahora sino también por lo que os voy a
contar a continuación
además quería ponerme a prueba a mí
misma quería preparar esta charla mejor
y he de deciros que esta experiencia ha
marcado un antes y un después en mi vida
tanto personal como laboral
y llegados a este punto creo que es
importante que nos preguntemos cómo
narices hemos llegado hasta aquí como
sociedad porque no soy vosotros pero yo
no me dado ni cuenta bueno pues en 1994
nació se lanzó el primer smartphone pero
no fue hasta 2007 donde cambió todo
steve jobs presentó el teléfono
inteligente famosísimo que todos
conocemos y ahí fue donde la tecnología
digital se empezó a convertir en una
prolongación de nuestra mano
en 2004 nació facebook en 2006 nació
twitter empezaron a salir todas las
redes sociales y de repente había una
aplicación prácticamente para cualquier
cosa y nuestras vidas han cambiado no
vamos a juzgar de momento si para bien o
para mal pero lo que está claro es que
han cambiado y muchísimo
hace como 8 meses o así estuve
trabajando en una empresa lo que
hacíamos en esta empresa era evaluar con
realidad virtual algunas funciones del
cerebro como la atención la memoria o la
impulsividad y en este contexto de
trabajar en esta empresa me interese
especialmente por aprender cómo se
formaba una adicción
una adicción no es otra cosa que un
circuito neuronal que te impulsa a
recibir una recompensa a corto plazo no
te puedes esperar a largo plazo tiene
que ser ya
y sabéis qué es lo que utilizamos todos
los días y que es tan o más adictivo que
el alcohol o que la nicotina pues las
redes sociales sí y por qué son tan
adictivas porque esa anticipación de la
gratificación en forma del aire en forma
de comentario etcétera hace que tu
cerebro se agregue una sustancia que se
llama dopamina y que te hace sentir muy
bien
de hecho las redes sociales están
diseñadas expresamente para ser lo más
adictivas posibles porque para que todos
nosotros pasemos el máximo tiempo dentro
de ellas por eso existen funcionalidades
como el scroll infinito que por si no lo
sabéis scroll es deslizar con tu dedo
pulgar y el scroll infinito es que
siempre va a haber contenido para ti
especialmente segmentado por el
algoritmo nunca y final
también por eso existen el sonido de las
notificaciones
o suena cuando escucháis esto nuestro
cerebro segrega dopamina y queréis esa
dosis
por eso también existen los famosos
likes que nos hacen sentir súper
reconocidos
a todo esto que os acabo de contar ya se
le ha puesto nombre está diagnosticado
se llama homofobia en inglés como fear
of missing out en español miedo o terror
a perdernos algo y es que el cerebro no
diferencia bien entre realidad real y
realidad virtual para él todo es
interacción todo es comunicación y por
una cuestión de supervivencia va a
priorizar la cantidad que la calidad
llevamos
si llevamos como 20 años del siglo 21 y
ahora estamos empezando a ver las
consecuencias de la revolución digital y
muchos nos preguntamos bueno entonces
la tecnología es mala es que son malas
las redes sociales yo personalmente creo
que no es malo en sí mismo creo que la
tecnología digital es un regalo un
regalo que hace posible cosas como que
podamos hablar con un ser querido que
está en la otra punta del mundo o que
todas las ideas que estáis disfrutando
hoy que están entrando en vuestro
cerebro para transformar vuestra mente
puedan llegar a cientos de miles de
personas porque todo esto se va a subir
a youtube
todo esto y mucho más es posible gracias
a la revolución digital sin embargo
nadie nos ha dado una guía de
instrucciones para lidiar con esto esto
no ha venido ni con una guía ni con un
prospecto de posibles contraindicaciones
de hecho si viniera con uno algunas de
las de los efectos secundarios podrían
ser homofobia ansiedad comportamientos
compulsivos chepa por estar todo el día
así trastornos del sueño
y muchas más
la evolución
y además de no tener una guía de
instrucciones es que tampoco tenemos
referentes
veréis ahora mismo hay una serie de
generaciones vivas en el mundo entre las
cuales están estas tres está la
generación x la generación y y la z la
generación x tiene entre 50 y 60 la
generación y 20 muchos treinta y pocos
en mi generación generación z tienen
entre 15 y 20 y pocos
la generación x es llamada los
inmigrantes digitales y la generación z
son los nativos digitales
los millennials es la mía somos una
especie de puente entre dos eras muy
distintas
pero estas dos generaciones la equis y
la y sí que han recibido educación sobre
cuestiones que han sido consideradas
importantes en su momento como por
ejemplo la educación vial o la educación
sexual sin embargo la generación de los
centenas no está recibiendo ni en sus
casas ni en sus centros educativos
educación digital y esto es ya un legado
totalmente insostenible
y es que cuantos de vosotros tenéis
hijos o nietos o sobrinos que no son
capaces de mantener una conversación sin
levantar la cara del móvil pero es que
acaso los adultos lo hacemos
si cuando nos sentamos a la mesa lo
primero que hacemos es sacar el móvil y
ponerlo en el al lado del plato
si cuando nos vamos a dormir para
recargar energía el móvil está a nuestro
lado recargándose también con nosotras
ante esto lo que yo propongo hoy aquí
es que para afrontar los retos del
futuro las nuevas generaciones y las
notas nuevas empiecen a recibir
educación digital
y no me refiero a que les enseñamos cómo
usarlo sino cómo usarlo y esto es lo que
va a marcar la diferencia entre avanzar
en una dirección menos peligrosa para
nosotros o simplemente no hacerlo
educación digital cómo podemos afrontar
este reto yo os voy a proponer dos pasos
el primero de ellos es darnos cuenta
hacer un clic reconocer todos que
tenemos un problema en la sociedad no
para sentir miedo o sentirnos amenazados
sino para ver aquí una oportunidad de
cambiar algo y este es el gran porqué de
esta charla hacer ese clic
y el segundo paso es obviamente que se
hace cuando tienes un problema pues
buscarle soluciones buscar cómo
resolverlo y cómo podríamos resolver
esto bueno yo voy a plantear tres
enfoques y seguramente la respuesta será
una mezcla de los tres el primer enfoque
sería el formativo imaginaos una
educación donde se impartiera y se
impartirán clases en productividad
habilidades sociales empatía pero todo
eso relacionado con la educación digital
ya con el mundo digital
por ejemplo empatía tras la pantalla
para prevenir entre otras cosas el ciber
bullying y muchos ejemplos más
otro enfoque sería el conciliador es
decir con la propia tecnología que no es
nuestra enemiga cogerla y adaptarla para
que nos ayude a implementar hábitos
saludables por ejemplo en facebook o en
instagram ya podéis mirar desde hace
algunos meses cuánto tiempo pasáis
dentro de la red social porque no
empezamos a incorporar este hábito de
mirar cuánto tiempo le dedicamos también
hay otras aplicaciones que contabilizan
las veces que desbloqueas el móvil o
cuánto tiempo pasa haciendo scroll
también podríamos mirarlo incluso las
hay que van más allá
hay una aplicación que por cada día que
cumples tu cometido de no pasar más de
equis tiempo conectado planta un árbol
por ti en la vida real
y bueno la tercera el tercer enfoque un
poco por descarte sería el restrictivo
es decir prohibir
pero estas delicadas porque estas
alturas de la película ya no podemos
negar la revolución digital porque es
que la revolución digital ha venido
totalmente a quedarse y depende de
nosotros el lugar que le dejemos ocupar
en nuestra vida
porque no en lugar de tenerle miedo a la
tecnología o sentirnos amenazados por
ella la abrazamos pero tomando las
riendas nosotros para que no sea ella la
que se adueña de nuestro tiempo de
nuestros hábitos y de nuestra atención
un cuchillo lo puedes utilizar para
matar a alguien o para untar una tostada
es una elección que tú haces pues esto
es lo mismo es una decisión que tenemos
que tomar
entonces que os apuntáis a desconectar
un poco de esto para volver a conectar
con tigo mismo y con tu entorno
os apuntáis a un futuro donde exista la
educación digital porque si la respuesta
es sí os aseguro que nos vamos a ver
allí y antes de terminar
me gustaría que escuchar a alguien que
tiene algo que deciros
tienes un mensaje nuevo estás deseando
leerlo verdad
qué vas a hacer
quién decides eres tú
[Música]
tenéis un mensaje en
en vuestros reposabrazos los que podáis
aguantar leerlo en casa y los que no
pues os podéis comer un caramelo gracias
[Aplausos]